la guitare semi acoustique de kurt
cobain mise aux enchères à un million
d'euros
une folie qui va à l'encontre de la
philosophie du chanteur le grunge
un mouvement qui débarque dans les
années 90 en france et que les
journalistes tentaient alors de nous
expliquer pour terminer ce journal une
page grunge et vous ne connaissez
peut-être pas forcément la signification
de ce mot anglais qui ne se traduit pas
vraiment mais qui qualifie un style un
peu particulier actuellement en vogue
chez les adolescents et qui donne libre
cours à un certain relâchement
vestimentaire
certains se risquent et même à une
traduction grunge et écologiquement ça
vient d'un mot américain qui veut dire
la crasse qu'on peut découvrir entre les
doigts de pieds de grunge c'est avant
tout un style de musique né à seattle
mais il s'accompagne d'un style
vestimentaire bien à lui voici comment
une ado de 1993 le définissent et
récupération pour sa vie avec les plus
habiles mais le drunch ça va au delà du
look c'est un état d'esprit on refuse
toutes obligations baissent les bras on
vit dans le présent
en devenant et de mode cool le grunge ce
serait vidé de son sens c'est ce que
dénonce et les purs et durs les moyens
mis à la disposition de tous les êtres
la scène de seattle actuellement fait
que
les enregistrements se font dans des
conditions je dirais top qualité et
c'est vrai qu'à ce prix est correct ont
perdu un esprit perdu la marchandisation
d'une philosophie à la base
opposé à la société de consommation tout
ça désolé aussi kurt cobain considéré
comme le leader du mouvement grunge en
avril 1994 kurt cobain met fin à ses
jours
tous les jt en parle un suicide qui
parle pour une génération titre ce soir
le washington post
kurt cobain le chanteur du groupe
nirvana inde et comprend que les plus
populaires du monde s'est tiré une balle
dans la tête il incarnait le mouvement
grunge
un mouvement qui va perdurer et le
groupe lui va devenir un mythe qui peut
rapporter gros
comme ce fan qui décide en 2016 de
vendre une guitare que kurt cobain lui
avait donné après un concert j'avais
juré je m'en séparerai pas mais bon on
m'enlèvera pas le souvenir s'est jamais
qu'un objet bonbons à l'époque j'avais
des cheveux j'avais pas de vie et
j'avais pas de crédits immobiliers etc
voilà quoi le grunge avec un crédit immo
bien loin du collant troué et de la
chemise à carreaux
[Musique]